across the country more than half a
million people rely on a service dog in
their everyday life these elite dogs are
the product of months of schooling and
not all puppies that begin training have
what it takes to become a service dog if
a pup doesn't live up to the strict
standards required they will fail out
which puppies have the brains and
behavior to make it through the rigors
of training we find out in puppy prep
[Music]
on the California coastline about
halfway between Los Angeles and San
Francisco sits a royal grande a small
community of beaches mountains and
wineries just outside of town is doggie
Doo good
a training and obedience school
specializing in the education of service
dogs depending on the dog
the journey from carefree puppy to hero
can take anywhere from six months to
more than a year not all dogs make it
through the process if a dog flunks out
its put up for adoption at any given
time
there are dozens of service dogs in
training at doggie do-good the abilities
they learn range from retrieval to
stability pressure therapy medical
alerts simply kisses and much more what
they learn depends upon what each
individual dog is predisposed to for
instance yellow lab Deakin specializes
in retrieval and stability good steady
at almost two years old he's older than
many of the dogs that have already
graduated he was a stubborn pup and
though he had come close to flunking out
he is now only weeks from potential
graduation still he can't coast until
the minute before graduating trainers
are watching the dogs for any sign that
they won't be able to cut it right now
Deakin and his classmates are working on
basic come drills the pups run around
the lawn and play and one by one the
trainer's call out to them the most
important thing a dog needs to learn is
the difference between playtime and work
time
while it's alright for the dogs to act
like puppies as soon as the trainer
calls them they need to snap into work
mode these drills help solidify that
skill for veteran like Deacon this is
simple if Deacon is a senior in service
dog hi one of the incoming freshmen is
kaya an 8 month old golden retriever
kaya is beautiful and I love her if she
fails out of school during training I
will be trying to adopt her and right
off the bat she's having a problem see
kaya enjoys the company of people over
other dogs while it's good to be
comfortable around people she can't
remain nervous around other dogs if
she's going to pass training kaya's half
sister Remmy is also starting class
though they share a dad and are almost
the same age Remi has a completely
different personality Remi loves to play
with other dogs and often tries to pull
her half sister out of her doggy shell
for the especially young pups like
six-month-old chocolate lab Benelli
learning the come command begins on a
long leap a trainer calls Benelli and
gives a gentle tug this one little pole
is all the puppy needs to come the rest
of the way until she recognizes the
command the leash helps Benelli
understand what the english-speaking
humans are trying to communicate to her
doggy ears so far she's doing an all
Clio stop getting everyone into trouble
keep it up finale and you'll be off that
leash in no time after this morning
exercise it's time to try something more
subdued most of a service dogs time
isn't spent running around or actively
working instead being calm and on-call
ready at a moment's notice to help the
puppies must lay down and not get
distracted for long stretches of time
trainers tossed toys around to make sure
the dogs will choose their jobs over
pure playtime
whenever a dog breaks from their
downstate
it isn't enough for the dog to simply
lay back down the trainer needs to take
the dog back to the position where they
were otherwise a puppy won't understand
the gravity of getting up if a dog is
always distracted and can't learn to
focus that's the quickest way to fail
puppy prep Caius brother Luke is late to
class
he spent the morning off-site with a
trainer and without having had the
morning to run around like the rest of
his classmates Luke may be too bored to
sit still
Benelli all you have to do is literally
stay still if Benelli can't stay when
the ball is tossed over her head she may
become too distracted when taken out in
public
Remi come on you pups just need to relax
these two have just started so their
behavior isn't a huge problem yet kya
however is just as new and already too
pro and down-stay that's why you're my
favorite with most of the dogs being
unfazed by the toys it's time for some
livelier distractions oh my god it's mr.
pip mr. pip is beyond being absolutely
undeniable also a service dog in
training smaller dogs can comfort people
with anxiety as well as help alert
people with diseases like diabetes when
they need to take their medicine now
however his only job is to distract his
classmates most of the dogs don't fall
for the enchanting dance of mr. pip
except for tank the German Shepherd one
thing that tank needs to work on is his
prey Drive
small animals like cats and mr. pip can
distract larger dogs when they're with
their future owners tank must fight his
most basic instincts in order to pass
puppy prep now as for mr. pip he isn't
scared he is a job to do and he performs
it admirably god bless you mr. pip by
the end of the down-stay lesson it looks
like everyone's made progress
but there's one more test mercy a
Malinois with almost unlimited energy
mercy belongs to sandy the owner of
doggy Doo good immaculately schooled
mercy acts as a four-legged trainer
squeaking the toy just as the people
trainers would Mercy's claimed a victim
with only a month from his planned
graduation deikun should know better
than to break from downstate if he
continues to lose focus he may have to
stay in school for extra months or worse
flunk out as for the other dogs they've
taken their lessons well for most it's
still early in their service dog
training as long as they can keep making
progress
the puppies show good promise of
graduating kaya in particular shows a
lot of potential especially for her
young age and upbringing unlike her
brother Luke who was raised since birth
by trainers at doggie doo good kaya went
off to a puppy raiser family many of the
dogs at doggie do good and live with a
foster family for the first few months
of their life there they learned the
most basic behaviors like potty training
when pups reached six to eight months
they returned to doggy doo good to begin
service dog school
kaya's family dropped her off a few
weeks ago and she's seen them only once
since today however they're back for a
visit
when trainer Paul brings kaya outside
she thinks she's going for a walk what
she doesn't know is that the family that
raised her is waiting around the corner
[Music]
during their trainings it's easy to
forget how young the dogs are when
allowed to roll around with their former
family kaya is all puppy
even if foster father array wants to
make sure she still behaves puppy
raisers are a crucial part of the
service dog process and often one of the
bottlenecks to training service dogs
newborn puppies need near constant
attention to learn the basics of
obedience
good girl and while it's fun for the
family to raise a puppy knowing they
have to say goodbye in a few short
months can be difficult
kaya's family is proud of the job she'll
someday have and while they still miss
kaya the family thinks that soon they'll
be ready to take another puppy to help
begin its journey to becoming a service
dog at the end of the day the good boys
and good girls at doggy do good have
taken another step toward becoming fully
trained service dogs
but tomorrow is another day filled with
new challenges and distractions that
could ruin a dog's career which puppies
have what it takes mr. pip
[Music]